Shure: 这梗就callback才有意思呢
Shure: This joke only makes sense if you call it back.
Lucia: 虽然我也觉得挺搞笑
Lucia: Although I also find it pretty funny.
Shure: 像极了初入职场的我们
Shure: It totally reminds me of when we first started working.
其他人：有点像回到了农村
Others: It kind of feels like we're back in the countryside.
Tasha: 农村站着吃席
Tasha: Like eating at a banquet in the countryside.
其他人：站着吃席
Others: Standing while eating.
Katrina:  昨晚吃什么家常菜
Katrina: What did you have for dinner last night?
Katrina:  我就记得那个什么番茄牛腩
Katrina: I just remember the tomato beef brisket.
Katrina:  就跟一锅汤一样
Katrina: It was like a soup.
Lucia: 嗯对对对是汤
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, it was a soup.
Katrina:  点的外卖
Katrina: Ordered takeout.
Katrina:  然后晚上做了小蛋糕
Katrina: Then made some small cakes in the evening.
其他人：你们几天是不是该做菜了
Others: Shouldn't you be cooking now?
Katrina:  今天吃火锅
Katrina: We're having hotpot today.
Katrina:  你们今天吃晚饭吗
Katrina: Are you guys having dinner here?
Katrina:  在这里
Katrina: Here?
其他人：你在这吃不来都来了
Others: You're eating here since you came.
Shure:  他本来打算马上就走听完这个
Shure: He originally planned to leave right after this.
Katrina:  不不走
Katrina: No, I'm not leaving.
Katrina:  应该够吧
Katrina: Should be enough, right?
Katrina:  昨天买的
Katrina: Bought it yesterday.
Katrina: 那昨天买的菜应该够吧
Katrina: The groceries from yesterday should be enough.
Katrina: 多加俩人
Katrina: Add two more people.
其他人：哎前天不是拿出来好几个可乐吗
Others: Didn't we take out a few Cokes the day before?
Shure: 拿两个锅
Shure: Grab two pots.
Katrina: 嗯这楼下几个锅啊
Katrina: Hmm, how many pots downstairs?
Lucia: 啊楼下几个锅
Lucia: Ah, how many pots downstairs?
Alice:嗯楼下一个
Alice: Hmm, just one downstairs.
Alice:一个火锅的锅
Alice: One hotpot pot.
Katrina: 电磁炉呢
Katrina: What about the induction cooker?
Katrina: 有电磁炉没
Katrina: Do we have an induction cooker?
Alice:电磁炉没注意
Alice: Didn't notice the induction cooker.
Tasha: 我看有一个
Tasha: I saw one.
Tasha: 那个瓦斯
Tasha: That gas stove.
Lucia: 我们这有电磁炉吗
Lucia: Do we have an induction cooker here?
Shure: 哦瓦斯炉那种
Shure: Oh, the gas stove kind.
Tasha: 对卡磁炉也可以煮
Tasha: Yeah, the gas stove can cook too.
其他人：那有一个
Others: There's one.
其他人：那个微波炉这有
Others: There's a microwave here.
Shure: 我们煮火锅你用微波炉
Shure: We're cooking hotpot, and you use a microwave?
其他人：电磁炉
Others: Induction cooker
其他人：你们怎么用这种眼神看着我
Others: Why are you looking at me like that?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 没事我们这这个数学题不歧视任何
Shure: No worries, our math problem doesn't discriminate against anyone.
Shure: 呵呵有些不歧视任何
Shure: Haha, doesn't discriminate against anyone.
其他人：不歧视任何傻子
Others: Doesn't discriminate against any fools.
其他人：我没说啊
Others: I didn't say that.
Tasha: 用微波炉煮火锅
Tasha: Cooking hotpot with a microwave.
其他人：我没听明白上半句说的啥
Others: I didn't understand the first part.
Shure: 我刚刷到那个
Shure: I just saw that.
Shure: 监狱密不透风那些人总是怎么进去的
Shure: How do people get into those airtight prisons?
Shure: 然后回答第一名是专法律空子进去的
Shure: And the top answer was, they go in by exploiting legal loopholes.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: 这什么弱智吧吗
Lucia: What kind of nonsense is that?
其他人：我靠这个很有深意
Others: Wow, that's deep.
其他人：还得是弱智吧
Others: Still nonsense, though.
Alice:杨老板是不是还没吃
Alice: Has Jake eaten yet?
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake
Alice:不用睡觉也不用吃饭
Alice: Doesn't need sleep or food.
Katrina: 完了吃光了
Katrina: Oh no, he ate everything.
Lucia: 他不会是机器人吧
Lucia: Maybe he's a robot.
Katrina: 他才是真正的AI
Katrina: He's the real AI.
Shure: 他改造了我们啊
Shure: He transformed us.
Shure:  他有一半的位置他改造
Shure: He has modified himself.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Katrina: 他改造了他自己
Katrina: He modified himself.
Katrina: 会不会脑子有芯片呢呵呵呵
Katrina: Maybe he has a chip in his brain, haha.
Shure: 就是意志你知道意志是什么吗
Shure: It's all about willpower, you know what that is?
Tasha: 他昨天晚上嗯就在这
Tasha: He was just here last night.
Katrina:  哎我看见我想上厕所
Katrina: I saw him, I wanted to go to the bathroom.
Katrina:  看见他但还没睡
Katrina: I saw him, but he wasn't sleeping.
Shure: 几点钟几点
Shure: What time was it?
Tasha: 三四点吧
Tasha: Around 3 or 4 AM.
其他人：我靠
Others: Wow.
Katrina: 你也没睡吗
Katrina: You weren't sleeping either?
Shure: 太吓人了
Shure: That's creepy.
Shure: 我半夜起来
Shure: I woke up in the middle of the night.
Shure: 看到一个人
Shure: And saw someone.
Tasha: 我两点多半夜上厕所的时候看到他
Tasha: I saw him when I went to the bathroom at around 2 AM.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Right.
Katrina: 我也是两点起来
Katrina: I also got up at 2.
Tasha: 然后他说
Tasha: Then he said
Tasha: 他说他还不困
Tasha: He said he wasn't sleepy.
呵呵
(Laughing)
Katrina:  特别像那种机器人管家
Katrina: Just like a robot butler.
Katrina: 晚上在这巡视
Katrina: Patrolling at night.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  没有这点精力读不了PhD
Katrina: You need that kind of energy to get a PhD.
Tasha: 然后他说他昨天5点半才睡
Tasha: Then he said he didn't sleep until 5:30.
Tasha: 对啊然后早上10点钟
Tasha: Yeah, then at 10 in the morning,
Tasha: 然后就起来了
Tasha: He got up.
其他人：他天天都8点多起来开会
Others: He gets up for a meeting every day at 8.
其他人：要晚上3点睡
Others: Sleeps at 3 AM.
其他人：然后8点起来开会
Others: Then up at 8 for a meeting.
Tasha: 天呐
Tasha: Oh my god.
其他人：挺恐怖
Others: That's scary.
Shure: 他可能睡觉一个小时多
Shure: He might sleep for just an hour.
Shure: 咱们两个小时
Shure: We get two hours.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 南孚电池
Katrina: Like a Nanfu battery.
Lucia: 你们怎么确定他这个是睡觉
Lucia: How do you know he's sleeping,
Lucia: 不是充电呢
Lucia: And not recharging?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 去他房间找一找有没有插头插座
Katrina: Check his room for any plugs or sockets.
Shure: 哈哈哈嗯
Shure: Hahaha, yeah.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
其他人：有点怪哈哈
Others: That's kinda weird, haha.
Katrina: 逐渐怪异了起来
Katrina: Getting weirder and weirder.
Shure: 好像确实有
Shure: Seems like it.
Lucia: 刚刚这个对话应该本人在的时候更搞笑一点
Lucia: This conversation would be funnier if he was here.
Lucia: 他还没在
Lucia: He's not here yet.
Shure: 其实
Shure: Actually,
Shure: 这些摄像头都接触杨老板的那个
Shure: All these cameras are connected to Jake's
Shure: 脑机接口里面
Shure: Brain interface.
Shure: 嗯就他时时都能看到我
Shure: Yeah, he can see me all the time.
Shure: 天眼懂吗
Shure: Like the Eye of Heaven, you know?
Katrina: 好像真没菜了
Katrina: Seems like we're out of food.
Shure: 杨老板要机械飞升了
Shure: Jake's going to ascend to the machine realm.
Alice:他来了哈哈
Alice: Here he comes, haha.
Alice:放一首非诚勿扰开场曲
Alice: Play the opening song from "If You Are the One."
Katrina: 我觉得特别热
Katrina: I feel so hot.
Jake: 哈哈什么东西
Jake: Haha, what's that?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
其他人：你再重新出去一遍
Others: Try going out again.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 我们给你放BGM你在进
Shure: We'll play some BGM for you to come in.
Jake: 好行
Jake: Okay, sure.
Jake: 搬个椅子上来
Jake: Bring a chair up.
Lucia: 他真的出去了
Lucia: He actually went out.
Tasha: 情绪稳定
Tasha: Stay calm.
Katrina:  真的很像一只水豚
Katrina: Really looks like a capybara.
Katrina: 我觉得二楼好热啊
Katrina: I think the second floor is so hot.
Lucia: 对二楼比一楼要热
Lucia: Yeah, it's hotter than the first floor.
Katrina: 我昨晚开空调了哦
Katrina: I turned on the air conditioner last night.
Lucia: 哎我好像
Lucia: Oh, I seem to...
Katrina: 我卧室里没有空调我都没注意
Katrina: There's no air conditioner in my bedroom, I didn't even notice.
Shure: 不知道谁给我开开的
Shure: I don't know who turned it on for me.
Shure: 就是我躺着躺着突然就开了
Shure: I was just lying there and suddenly it was on.
Tasha: 是我开的
Tasha: I turned it on.
Shure: 为什么
Shure: Why?
Tasha: 我不是在你躺着时候开的呀
Tasha: I didn't turn it on while you were lying there.
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Ha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 气质是不是不太对
Jake: Isn't the vibe a bit off?
Lucia: 我们稍微往那边挪一点吧
Lucia: Let's move a bit over there.
Tasha: 有一位吃完了
Tasha: Someone's finished eating.
Katrina:  逐出
Katrina: Get out.
Shure: 这怎么还没到那个呢
Shure: Why isn't it there yet?
Lucia: 要不再走一遍
Lucia: Should we go over it again?
Lucia: 重拍一条
Lucia: Let's reshoot that.
Jake: 重拍
Jake: Reshoot.
Shure: 哎这才是呢
Shure: Ah, this is it.
Jake: 好下午一定
Jake: Okay, definitely this afternoon.
Jake: 等这个都开了
Jake: Once it's all set up.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake: 有饭吗嗯好谢谢
Jake: Is there food? Oh, great, thanks.
其他人：筷子还有
Others: There are chopsticks.
Alice: 要不用勺
Alice: Want to use a spoon instead?
Lucia:  嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:我今天拆出了一根隐藏款
Alice: I found a hidden item today.
Jake: 好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Katrina:  哈哈哈 3只筷子他那个
Katrina: Hahaha, three chopsticks, that one.
Jake: 这怎么吃
Jake: How do you eat this?
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 打开补充装
Lucia: Open the refill pack.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 三脚架
Jake: Tripod.
Katrina:  要开空调吗好热
Katrina: Should we turn on the air conditioner? It's so hot.
Katrina:  找找我那个
Katrina: Look for my...
Tasha: 空调遥控器在我房间里
Tasha: The air conditioner remote is in my room.
Shure: 小爱同学
Shure: Hey Alexa.
Jake: 哈什么
Jake: What?
Katrina:  我房间也有空调
Katrina: There's also an air conditioner in my room.
其他人：遥控器
Others: Remote.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人：那你拿一下
Others: Then go get it.
Tasha: 他挡住我的门了
Tasha: He's blocking my door.
Katrina:  我来
Katrina: I'll do it.
Tasha: 哦你也有
Tasha: Oh, you have one too.
Shure: 咦惨不忍睹
Shure: Ugh, it's unbearable.
Jake: 对但是他OK
Jake: Yeah, but he's okay.
其他人：你这个眼镜很有迷惑性
Others: Those glasses are really confusing.
Katrina:  这能通用吗
Katrina: Can this be used universally?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  应该可以吧
Katrina: It should be fine, right?
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Yes, yes.
Katrina:  直接开始吧
Katrina: Let's just start.
Shure: 哦一会把我那屋空调关一下
Shure: Oh, can someone turn off the air conditioner in my room later?
Shure: 我一直没有遥控器
Shure: I never had the remote.
Alice:那天我跟杨老板借遥控器
Alice: The other day, I borrowed the remote from Jake.
Jake: 你说
Jake: Go on.
Alice:然后我想试一下这个遥控器能不能用
Alice: Then I wanted to test if this remote would work.
Alice: 就把他房间开开
Alice: So I turned on his room's air conditioner.
Shure: 然后突然把我房间到现在才一直是开
Shure: And then my room's been on ever since.
Shure: 然后他一会吹冷风一会吹热风
Shure: Sometimes it blows cold air, sometimes hot air.
Jake: 所以所以是什么模式啊
Jake: So, so what's the mode?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 不知道是什么模式
Shure: No idea what mode it's on.
Shure: 他太奇怪了
Shure: It's just too weird.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright then.
Shure:  然后
Shure: And then...
Shure:  我那屋就陷入一个特别尴尬的温度
Shure: My room ended up being at a really awkward temperature.
Shure: 又不冷又不热的一个
Shure: Neither cold nor hot.
Tasha: 不冷不热特别好嘛
Tasha: Not cold nor hot is actually pretty good.
Katrina:  这不是很适宜吗宜居啊
Katrina: Isn't that quite comfortable and livable?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 盖被还嫌热
Shure: If I use a blanket, it's too hot.
Shure: 不盖被还嫌热
Shure: If I don't use a blanket, it's still hot.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Jake: 这这什么菜啊
Jake: What dish is this?
Tasha: 烤番茄
Tasha: Baked tomatoes.
Katrina:  年糕烧鸡
Katrina: Rice cake with chicken.
Jake: 土豆吗嗯
Jake: Potatoes, right?
Tasha: 年糕鸡
Tasha: Rice cake with chicken.
Jake:年糕鸡
Jake: Rice cake with chicken.
Katrina:  味道还不错
Katrina: The taste is pretty good.
Katrina:  就是它分量有点少
Katrina: Just the portion is a bit small.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  早知道应该再多点两餐
Katrina: Should have ordered two more servings.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
其他人：这个
Others: This one.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Katrina:  开空调了
Katrina: Turn on the air conditioning.
其他人： 我以为是糖醋
Others: I thought it was sweet and sour.
Lucia: 我以为是被塑料的东西
Lucia: I thought it was plastic-wrapped stuff.
Tasha: 没尝出他的东西
Tasha: Didn't taste it properly.
Lucia: 包括这个也很奇怪
Lucia: This one's also quite strange.
Lucia: 就是他又有点像辣白菜味
Lucia: It kinda tastes like kimchi.
Lucia: 又有点像水煮什么的味啊
Lucia: But also like boiled something.
Tasha: 什么什么泡菜
Tasha: What kind of kimchi?
Tasha:  不知道从从上往下点
Tasha: Don't know, tasted from top to bottom.
Katrina:  知道从从上往下点了一遍哈哈哈
Katrina: Yeah, tasted from top to bottom, haha.
Tasha: 不知道这两个菜我都没有尝过
Tasha: I haven't tried these two dishes.
Tasha: 我只经常吃这两个菜
Tasha: I usually eat these two dishes.
其他人：这就是那个人
Others: That's that person.
其他人：人气榜前面
Others: Top of the popularity list.
Tasha: 呃就是我经常爱吃的两个菜
Tasha: These are my favorite two dishes.
Jake: 这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 哪家呀韩国
Jake: Which place, Korea?
Tasha: 因为这是土门吧
Tasha: Because this is Tumun, right?
其他人：米村拌饭
Others: Micun mixed rice.
Jake: 这叫米村
Jake: This is called Micun.
Tasha: 不是韩国是朝鲜
Tasha: It's not South Korea, it's North Korea.
Alice:朝鲜非遗
Alice: North Korean intangible cultural heritage.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人：查一查还没吃过这个
Others: Look it up, we haven't tried this before.
Jake: 朝鲜米村
Jake: North Korean Micun.
Jake: 朝鲜有是是这意思吗
Jake: Is there a place called Micun in North Korea?
Jake: 朝鲜有一个地方叫米村
其他人： 米村可能是个人
Others: Micun might be a person.
其他人：米村就是姓米的他家的村
Others: Micun is just a village of someone with the surname Mi.
Jake: 哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 那土村
Tasha: Then there's Tumun.
Jake: 哈
Jake: Haha.
其他人：还真是那个朝鲜料理
Others: It really is that North Korean dish.
Jake: 人
Jake: People.
Tasha: 我都说了是朝鲜料理
Tasha: I told you it's North Korean food.
其他人：不是不是看错了
Others: No, no, we got it wrong.
Jake: 日本人这个名字听起来
Jake: It sounds like a Japanese name.
其他人： 这是什么东西
Others: What is this stuff?
Jake: 这个大麻茶哪来的呀
Jake: Where did this hemp tea come from?
Tasha: 大麻茶哈哈
Tasha: Hemp tea, haha.
其他人：冰箱里冰箱里
Others: From the fridge, from the fridge.
其他人： 你喝可乐啊
Others: Drink cola.
Jake: 昨天买的是吗
Jake: Did you buy it yesterday?
Jake: 对嗯
Jake: Yeah, right.
Shure: 人家大妈馋
Shure: The aunt is craving it.
Shure: 就是领导要啥你给
Shure: Just give the boss whatever they want.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈你
Jake: Hahaha, you...
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 怎么在北京活下来的
Shure: How did you survive in Beijing?
Jake: 哈哈哈还
Jake: Haha, still...
Tasha: 还好老板不是北京人
Tasha: Good thing the boss isn't from Beijing.
Shure: 你快去山东进修两年
Shure: You should go to Shandong for training for two years.
Tasha: 做事滴水不漏
Tasha: Do things flawlessly.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 这个能录吗
Jake: Can we record this?
Shure:  哈哈哈这教AI做人哈哈哈
Shure: Haha, teaching AI how to be human, haha.
Shure: 咱不能这么说
Shure: We can't say that.
Shure:  应该叫AI做机
Shure: Should call it AI doing work
Jake: 哈哈哈这情况
Jake: Hahaha, this situation
Katrina:  更奇怪了
Katrina: It's getting weirder
Shure: 想什么呢
Shure: What are you thinking
Shure:  这写成文本一点毛病没有
Shure: Writing it as a text is totally fine
Shure:  想歪了是你心脏
Shure: If you think otherwise, it's your problem
Shure:  干什么
Shure: What are you doing
Lucia: 你在扫描周围环境吗
Lucia: Are you scanning the surroundings?
Jake: 没有我在看灯有没有亮
Jake: No, I'm checking if the light is on
Jake: 下午整啥来着
Jake: What are we doing this afternoon?
Jake: 下午
Jake: Afternoon
其他人：他们是要跳舞吗
Others: Are they going to dance?
Jake: 跳舞对
Jake: Dance, yes
Tasha: 你要跳吗
Tasha: Are you dancing?
其他人：我吗
Others: Me?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah
Jake: 你要跳吗
Jake: Are you dancing?
其他人：你教我我就跳
Others: If you teach me, I will dance
Tasha: 编剧都
Tasha: The scriptwriters
Jake: 那可以跳
Jake: Then you can dance
Tasha: 编剧也都要跳的
Tasha: The scriptwriters also have to dance
其他人：可以跳
Others: Can dance
Tasha: 可以跳我们刚刚说好了
Tasha: We just agreed we can dance
Jake: 嗯好
Jake: Okay, good
Jake: 那可以跳
Jake: Then you can dance
Tasha: 你跳吗
Tasha: Are you dancing?
Jake: 跳他肯定跳
Jake: He will definitely dance
其他人： 他肯定跳
Others: He will definitely dance
其他人：我可以不跳
Others: Can I not dance?
Tasha: 那我们七个人了
Tasha: Then we are seven people
Tasha: 哈哈七仙女
Tasha: Haha, seven fairies
其他人：谁不跳
Others: Who's not dancing?
其他人：我不跳了
Others: I'm not dancing
其他人： 他不跳
Others: He's not dancing
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
其他人：选好了那个
Others: Have we chosen that one?
Lucia: 哎咱选了吗
Lucia: Hey, have we chosen?
Alice:yes ok 吗
Alice: Yes, is it ok?
Katrina: 跳yes ok
Katrina: Dance, yes, okay
Katrina: 我看看
Katrina: Let me check
Jake: 跳过吗
Jake: Should we skip it?
其他人：没有
Others: No.
Jake: 跳过吗
Jake: Should we skip it?
Katrina: 几分钟来着
Katrina: How many minutes was it?
Katrina: 一分半一分52
Katrina: One and a half, one fifty-two.
Tasha: 啊这个你跳肯定很
Tasha: Ah, if you jump, it's definitely...
Tasha: 适合你
Tasha: Suitable for you.
Jake: 紫藤最近什么时候来啊
Jake: When is Zitong coming next?
Jake: 不知道啊
Jake: No idea.
Katrina:  哈哈没事他带头
Katrina: Haha, it's fine, he can lead.
Tasha: 我以为那个是放大声音
Tasha: I thought that was to increase the volume.
Katrina:  让这个叫什么
Katrina: Let, what's his name...
Katrina:  修硕带头
Katrina: Shure lead.
Katrina: 其实还好吧不是
Katrina: Actually, it's fine, not really...
Jake: 修硕亮相是吧哈哈哈
Jake: Shure, make an appearance, right? Haha.
其他人：正好七个人
Others: Exactly seven people.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
其他人：草正好七个人
Others: Geez, exactly seven people.
其他人：没有我是吧
Others: No, am I included?
Jake: 有你有你
Jake: Yes, you are.
其他人：奥草加上我7个
Others: Oh, with me, it's seven.
其他人：哈哈嗯草
Others: Haha, yeah, geez.
Katrina:  哈哈哈3个男生4个女生
Katrina: Hahaha, three guys and four girls.
Jake: 处到位处到位是吧处到位
Jake: In position, in position, right? In position.
Jake: 没进
Jake: Didn't get in.
其他人：要不要
Others: Do you want to?
其他人： 练一下直接去
Others: Practice a bit, then go straight.
其他人：什么练动直接去
Others: What practice, just go straight.
Tasha: 哦是练习生
Tasha: Oh, it's the trainees.
Jake: 练习生练习生啊
Jake: Trainees, trainees, huh?
Jake: 你这头发还挺好的
Jake: Your hair is pretty good.
其他人：没事
Others: It's fine.
Tasha: 我天那
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake: 这头发值得solo一下
Jake: This hair deserves a solo.
其他人：没问题
Others: No problem.
Katrina:  都是起舞吧
Katrina: Everyone, start dancing.
Jake: 就是独舞独舞一下
Jake: Do a solo, solo.
Tasha: 噢噢噢噢噢
Tasha: Oh, oh, oh.
Lucia:  可以给他插入一个solo段落吧
Lucia: Maybe we can insert a solo section for him?
Tasha:  要不啊
Tasha: Or...
Tasha:  就是那种拍那种转场
Tasha: Like those transition shots
Tasha:  然后一个人出来跳
Tasha: And then one person comes out to dance
Lucia: 对对对就比如说大家知道队形
Lucia: Yes, yes, for example, everyone knows the formation
Lucia: 跳完之后向两边散开
Lucia: After dancing, they spread out to the sides
Lucia: 然后一个人出来跳
Lucia: And then one person comes out to dance
Tasha: 然后在这这样子
Tasha: And then like this
Tasha: 然后他就一个人开始跳好对
Tasha: And then they start dancing alone, right
其他人：靠这么夸张
Others: Wow, that's so exaggerated
Lucia: 一些高光段落
Lucia: Some highlight segments
Katrina:  穿裙子不
Katrina: Wearing skirts or not
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
其他人： 哈哈没问题
Others: Haha, no problem
Katrina:  没问题
Katrina: No problem
其他人： 我的腿不跟你开玩笑
Others: My legs are not kidding around
Jake: 哈哈哈是的是的
Jake: Hahaha, yes, yes
Katrina:  很可爱是的是的哈哈哈
Katrina: Very cute, yes, yes, hahaha
Shure: 可以扒吗
Shure: Can I strip it off
其他人：没问题
Others: No problem
其他人：踢足球的时候每个男的都来 摸我的腿
Others: When playing soccer, every guy comes to touch my legs
Jake: 为什么
Jake: Why
其他人：因为太诱人
Others: Because it's too tempting
Shure:  他长得像
Shure: He looks like
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈可以的
Katrina: Hahahahahaha, it's possible
Tasha: 这个是可以录的吗
Tasha: Can we record this
Katrina:  国外更那个
Katrina: It's even more so abroad
Shure: 都他妈是姐妹
Shure: They're all fucking sisters
Katrina:  也统一服装吗感觉他们那个
Katrina: Same outfit, right? They seem
Katrina:  很感兴趣
Katrina: Very interested
Jake: 统一什么服装
Jake: Same outfit
Jake: 就这个服装
Jake: Like this outfit
Katrina:  裙子
Katrina: Skirt
Jake: 裙子
Jake: Skirt
Jake: 可以那愿意拨款
Jake: Okay, willing to fund it
Katrina:  我找找教程哈哈
Katrina: I'll find some tutorials, haha
Katrina:  我哈哈什么
Katrina: I, haha, what
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake: 统一服装愿意拨款
Jake: Same outfit, willing to fund it
Katrina:  okay现在开始看
Katrina: Okay, let's start watching
Lucia: 老板大气
Lucia: Boss, you're generous
Tasha: 要不我来挑衣服吧
Tasha: How about I pick the clothes?
Lucia: 可以啊可以啊
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Shure:  真的统一服装啊
Shure: Really going with uniforms, huh?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Tasha:  哈哈哈老板都说拨款了
Tasha: Hahaha, the boss already said he's funding it.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Damn.
Katrina:  拨款呢
Katrina: Funding it.
其他人： 我操统一服装他妈还得把腿毛刮了
Others: Damn, with uniforms we even have to shave our leg hair.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Lucia: 你看人家已经开始认真考试了这是
Lucia: Look, they're already taking the exam seriously.
Katrina:  这这这个很有爱豆的觉悟
Katrina: This shows real idol determination.
Shure: 穿个厚一点的丝袜解决
Shure: Just wear thicker stockings to solve it.
Tasha: 要不大家穿裤子
Tasha: Or everyone could wear pants?
Katrina:  也行都可以
Katrina: That's fine too, anything works.
Tasha: 一定要穿裙子是吧
Tasha: Must we wear skirts?
Shure: 你也要这腿不漏白瞎
Shure: You have to, otherwise those legs would be wasted.
Lucia: 那我觉得我们邀请别人来的时候
Lucia: I think when we invite others over,
Lucia: 就有一个很大的卖点耶
Lucia: it would be a big selling point.
Katrina:  卖点哈哈
Katrina: Selling point, haha.
Shure: 我们这
Shure: For us,
Katrina:  卖点
Katrina: Selling point.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
其他人：那我不参加了
Others: Then I won't participate.
Katrina:  把他们三个把他们三个送出去
Katrina: Send those three out.
Jake: 你做个pose做个海报
Jake: Strike a pose for a poster.
Tasha: 诱骗失败了
Tasha: The lure failed.
其他人：我以为就今天跳了得了
Others: I thought we were just performing today.
其他人： 没想到今天只是排练
Others: Didn't expect today was just rehearsal.
Lucia: 嗯对今天只是排练
Lucia: Yes, today is just rehearsal.
Katrina:  刚刚敲定还没学
Katrina: We just finalized it, haven't learned it yet.
Jake: 对星期天
Jake: Yes, Sunday.
Jake: 星期天再跳
Jake: Dance on Sunday.
其他人：那我可以当导演
Others: Then I can be the director.
Tasha:  哈哈他要换个位置
Tasha: Haha, he wants to change roles.
其他人：跳不了一点
Others: Can't dance at all.
Jake: 好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Tasha: 好啊嗯那我也要到
Tasha: Okay, I'll be there too.
Katrina:  好稳定的情绪啊
Katrina: Such stable emotions.
Katrina:  我这哈哈
Katrina: I'm just, haha.
Katrina:  是不是跟他说什么好
Katrina: Should I say something to him?
Jake: 这梳子要扔吗
Jake: Should we throw this comb away?
Lucia: 啊这这个是放垃圾的吗
Lucia: Huh, is this for the trash?
其他人：不不不是
Others: No, no, no.
Alice:这是微微的梳子
Alice: This is Tasha's comb.
Lucia: 我看这里面有很多我感觉是
Lucia: I see a lot in here, I feel like...
Jake: 哦哦这个是素材是吧
Jake: Oh, oh, this is material, right?
Jake: 哈哈啊
Jake: Haha, oh.
Jake: 这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Lucia: 什么素材
Lucia: What material?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: No idea.
Jake: 水母素材
Jake: Jellyfish material.
其他人：出去一趟你能出吗
Others: Can you go out for a bit?
Tasha:  我这不能出
Tasha: I can't go out.
Tasha:  如果你愿意嫁给我
Tasha: If you're willing to marry me...
其他人： 啊不说了一会再说吧吃完再说
Others: Ah, stop it, let's talk about it later after eating.
Katrina:  从这下面走
Katrina: Go from below here.
其他人：你说这条路
Others: You mean this way?
Tasha:  没有没有
Tasha: No, no.
Tasha:  好我也出我也出
Tasha: Okay, I'll go too, I'll go too.
其他人：谢谢
Others: Thanks.
其他人：这个壶也是你们买的
Others: Did you guys buy this pot too?
Alice:不是吧
Alice: I don't think so.
Lucia: 他带的吧
Lucia: Maybe he brought it?
Katrina:  看咱还有啥
Katrina: Let's see what else we have.
Katrina:  我靠这包子扔了吧
Katrina: Whoa, should we throw these buns away?
Katrina:  乐的
Katrina: So happy.
Katrina: 这扔了吧
Katrina: Should we throw this away?
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:那个人带的
Alice: That person brought it.
Katrina:  哎我们没有交换礼物的环节
Katrina: Hey, we don't have a gift exchange session.
Jake: 有呃
Jake: We do, uh.
Jake: 晚上吧某个晚上吧某个晚上
Jake: At night, some night, some night.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 就今晚吧就今晚吧
Jake: Just tonight, let's do it tonight.
Katrina:  都行我只是提醒他有一个环节
Katrina: All right, I was just reminding that we have a session.
Jake: 好的好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Jake: 交换礼物
Jake: Gift exchange.
Katrina:  让我们自己带吗
Katrina: Are we bringing our own gifts?
Jake: 礼物
Jake: Gifts.
Katrina:  让我们自己带礼物吗
Katrina: Are we bringing our own gifts?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 这能说吗
Tasha: Can we talk about this?
Tasha: 还是别说了
Tasha: Or should we not say anything?
Katrina: 神秘
Katrina: Mysterious.
Lucia: 哈哈哈没有没有
Lucia: Hahaha, no, no.
Lucia:  哈哈不行
Lucia: Haha, no way.
Katrina: （歌词）it's ok   it's ok
Katrina: (singing) It's ok, it's ok.
Lucia:  懒得卸妆
Lucia: Too lazy to remove makeup.
Tasha: 现在
Tasha: Now?
Alice:不然你等会
Alice: Or later, whatever works.
Tasha: 都可以
Tasha: Either way is fine.
Katrina: 主要是修改文书这玩意
Katrina: Mainly it's about revising documents.
Katrina: 你找个同专业的
Katrina: Find someone in the same field.
Katrina: 然后比你厉害一点的人就够了
Katrina: Someone a bit more skilled than you, that's enough.
Katrina: 你不用觉得自己学不了什么的
Katrina: Don't think you can't learn anything.
Katrina: 我觉得2117.5%
Katrina: I think there's still a chance, 2117.5%.
Katrina: 其实还是有去终究的可能的哈
Katrina: There's still a possibility in the end.
Katrina: 然后你让他帮你看看
Katrina: Then ask them to help you review.
Katrina: 怎么帮你提高一下你的背书
Katrina: How to improve your backing document.
Katrina: 你要是觉得可以的话
Katrina: If you think it's okay.
Katrina:  你要是觉得可以的话我就给你们拉群
Katrina: If you think it's okay, I'll add you to the group.
Katrina: 慢慢吹慢慢吹
Katrina: Take it slow, take it slow.
Katrina: 哎呀衣服洗完了
Katrina: Oh, the laundry's done.
Katrina: 快晒衣服去
Katrina: Quick, hang the clothes.
Jake: 哎你这些操作能录就录好吧
Jake: Hey, if you can record these actions, go ahead.
Katrina: （歌词）哒哒哒哒
Katrina: (singing) Da da da da.
Katrina: 呀
Katrina: Ah.
Shure:  嗯那我现在戴个眼镜吧
Shure: Hmm, I'll put on my glasses now.
Katrina: 你干啥呢
Katrina: What are you doing?
Katrina: 通风
Katrina: Ventilating.
其他人：通一下风
Others: Ventilating a bit.
Katrina: 没事你先打开一会
Katrina: It's okay, just open it for a while.
Katrina: 我靠这晒干
Katrina: Wow, it's drying out.
其他人：刘帅
Others: Choiszt.
其他人：我怎么一股糊味
Others: Why do I smell something burnt?
其他人：没有糊味
Others: There's no burnt smell.
其他人：你他妈不会把楼烧了吧
Others: Did you burn down the building?
其他人：我怎么闻一股糊味
Others: Why do I smell something burnt?
Katrina:  今晚上没啥活动
Katrina: Nothing much happening tonight.
Katrina:  就准备一下火锅
Katrina: Let's get ready for hotpot.
Katrina:  看电影也行
Katrina: Or we could watch a movie.
其他人：那你们这挺爽啊
Others: That sounds awesome!
Katrina:  就是你知道今天早上特别离谱
Katrina: You know, this morning was so ridiculous.
Katrina:  今天早上他说10点钟开始
Katrina: He said we’d start at 10 AM.
Katrina:  但10点钟他们才起床
Katrina: But they didn’t get up until 10.
Katrina:  然后10点半开始
Katrina: So we started at 10:30.
Katrina:  然后坐这聊了一会天结束了哈哈
Katrina: Then we just sat around chatting for a bit and called it a day, haha.
Katrina:  这活真的很好
Katrina: This job is really easy.
Katrina:  就是随性到让我有点感
Katrina: It’s so laid back, I can’t believe it.
Katrina:  觉不可思议
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: Right?
Shure: 你拿那个钱拿的不安心
Shure: You don’t feel comfortable taking that money.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Exactly.
对
Katrina: Yeah.
其他人：他已经发现我们最后其实是不拨钱了
Others: He realized we actually don’t allocate the funds in the end.
Katrina:  哎他他给钱
Katrina: Oh, he gave the money.
Katrina:  他昨天还跟我们说
Katrina: He told us yesterday.
Katrina:  每人500块钱的经费装饰自己的房间
Katrina: Everyone gets 500 bucks to decorate their own room.
其他人：这是我想出来的这是我的idea
Others: That was my idea. That’s my idea.
Katrina:  可以而且我买了就直接带回去了
Katrina: Yeah, and I bought stuff and took it home directly.
Katrina:  公款买自己想要的东西
Katrina: Using company funds to buy things I want.
Shure: 是的这些最后全
Shure: Yeah, all of this in the end.
Katrina:  我靠就是你知道当时
Katrina: Wow, you know, at that time...
Katrina:  当时我面试的时候
Katrina: When I was interviewing...
Katrina:  我问他我说我们有什么流程
Katrina: I asked him what our procedures are.
Katrina:  他说待定
Katrina: He said "TBD."
Katrina:  我以为就是还没有你定好
Katrina: I thought it wasn’t finalized yet.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  我以为要保持一种神秘感
Katrina: I thought they wanted to keep a sense of mystery.
Katrina:  然后他现在发现
Katrina: But now I realize...
Katrina:  他连每天第二天的事情都没有决定
Katrina: He hasn’t even decided what to do the next day.
其他人：其实我们是准备了不过
Others: Actually, we prepared, but...
其他人：P人好吗
Others: People, right?
其他人：哈其实我们花了很长时间哈哈
Others: Haha, we spent a lot of time, haha...
其他人：但是很明显
Others: But clearly...
其他人：我们根本做不到
Others: We couldn’t do it at all.
Katrina:  很明显没有一个是按照那个来的
Katrina: Obviously, no one followed the plan.
Shure: 你是不干完这几天变成J人了
Shure: Are you going to change after these few days?
Katrina:  就是哇就真的待的我可不适应
Katrina: Wow, I really couldn’t get used to it.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know what?
Katrina:  我说我得上楼工作一会
Katrina: I said I need to go upstairs and work for a while.
Katrina:  就感觉就早上在这聊天
Katrina: It feels like just chatting here in the morning.
Katrina:  然后就像那种养老院的生活聊天
Katrina: And then it's like the kind of life chatting in a retirement home.
Katrina:  然后插插花
Katrina: Then arranging flowers.
Katrina:  然后洗洗衣服
Katrina: Then doing laundry.
Katrina:  溜一圈然后就回来
Katrina: Taking a stroll and then coming back.
Katrina:  回来然后早上跳了个舞
Katrina: Coming back and then dancing in the morning.
Katrina:  然后就就一直我的这个眼睛
Katrina: And then just my eyes constantly watching me play on my tablet.
Katrina:  就一直在看我玩平板
Katrina: Just constantly watching me play on my tablet.
Shure: 简直就退休了是吗
Shure: It's like you're already retired, right?
Katrina:  真退休我在学校都不敢这么摆
Katrina: If I were really retired, I wouldn't dare to be this relaxed at school.
Katrina:  哈哈哈自己房间装饰
Katrina: Haha, decorating my own room.
Katrina:  然后下午就是看淘宝
Katrina: And then in the afternoon, just browsing Taobao.
Shure: 然后这还给你钱
Shure: And they still pay you for this.
Katrina:  对还给钱
Katrina: Yes, they still pay me.
Katrina:  还给500块钱买自己
Katrina: They even gave me 500 yuan to spend on myself.
Katrina:  刚好我们家要搬家
Katrina: Just in time for us to move.
Katrina:  我新房间还没买东西
Katrina: My new room hasn't been furnished yet.
Katrina:  买了直接带过去
Katrina: I'll buy stuff and take it directly there.
Katrina:  直接从北京寄过去
Katrina: Send it directly from Beijing.
Katrina:  让我妈放我房间
Katrina: Let my mom put it in my room.
其他人：这里面是不已经没卡了
Others: Is there no card left inside?
Shure: 能拉但是它是不是花不一定
Shure: It can pull but it might not be latte art.
Shure: 它可能是屎
Shure: It might just be crap.
Shure: 我回家拉那些是不是都能
Shure: When I go home, can I pull all those?
其他人：咖啡机还能拉花
Others: The coffee machine can still make latte art.
其他人： 我回家我后来自己去拉也还行
Others: When I got home and tried it myself, it was still okay.
其他人：哎呀我操
Others: Oh my God.
Shure: 您悠着点
Shure: Take it easy.
Jake: 太幸福了
Jake: So happy.
Jake: 别摔摔了算工伤
Jake: Don't fall, it counts as a work injury.
Jake: 赔不起哈哈哈
Jake: Can't afford to compensate, haha.
其他人： 买个保险哈
Others: Buy insurance, haha.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 50块钱保险
Jake: 50 yuan insurance.
其他人：包含北京
Others: Including Beijing.
其他人：北京地区救援
Others: Beijing area rescue.
其他人：最近有一个新闻
Others: There was a news recently.
其他人：那个人
Others: That person...
Shure: 买的保险
Shure: The insurance we bought
其他人：不包含尼泊尔
Others: Doesn't cover Nepal
其他人：他他妈爬珠穆朗玛峰爬到尼泊尔去
Others: He freaking climbed Mount Everest into Nepal
其他人：在尼泊尔死了
Others: And died in Nepal
其他人：然后救不了
Others: Then couldn't be rescued
Shure:  呵呵呵他过国界的
Shure: Haha, he crossed the border
其他人：他妈太厉害了
Others: That's insane
Jake: 就特地写的不要尼泊尔是吧对
Jake: So it specifically says not Nepal, right?
其他人：对
Others: Yeah
Jake: 眼镜我来
Jake: I'll handle the glasses
Jake: 呃就现在可以停了吧
Jake: Uh, we can stop now, right?
Shure: 把我的眼镜给你传出去是吧
Shure: Sending my glasses out to you, right?
Jake: 传了对
Jake: Sent, yes